Every time you open your mouth and you
speak, people unconsciously categorize
you into one of these three categories.
Are you an awkward communicator? Are you
a pretty good communicator? Or are you a
natural communicator? And after 15 years
as a communication coach training
Fortune 500 companies and speaking to
millions of people around the world,
I've discovered that you can tell which
level someone sits at based on how they
use their voice, how they use their body
language, and how they use their words.
I'm going to explain the exact behaviors
at each level. So, by the end, you know
which category you're in, and you'll
know how to progress from one category
to the next. To make this even more fun,
we're going to put these people you see
here on the table into one of these
categories and see if you can guess
where they sit on the board. Well, why's
my face there, Ben? Well, Craig, it's so
we can demonstrate to the audience
there's a level lower than rookie.
>> [screaming]
>> Let's start with the rookie
communicator. And chances are most
people belong in this category without
even realizing it because they don't
know what they're doing wrong. It's a
stage called unconscious incompetence.
So, let me once and for all make you
aware on how to become a natural
communicator by first becoming more
aware of what makes a rookie. The first
thing that makes a rookie communicator
sound awkward is
flat delivery. There is no variation in
the way they speak. Every word at the
same speed, the same pitch, the same
volume, and the same emotion from the
first sentence to the last, kind of like
my GPS trying to point out directions to
help me find cheap fuel, which doesn't
exist anymore.
Thanks, Mr. Trump.
>> You're welcome. You're welcome. Then
there's vocal fry.
You know that low, creaky, gravelly
quality that happens to your voice when
you speak at the end of your breath.
Oh, hey Sam. How you going? Sam, I got a
quick question for you. What's an
average day of our work life going to
look like once AI agents and AI robots
take over the world? I don't really know
what this is going to feel like to live
through. Um I think we're in uncharted
waters here. Uh I do believe in like
human adaptability and sort of
>> Thank you, Sam. I'm going to stop you
right there. You see, that's a great
example of vocal fry and what not to do.
Sam, unfortunately, mate, you live right
here under rookie. Oh, and and and Sam,
please don't cancel my AI subscription.
I need it. Oh, how can we forget the um
uh
like you know what I'm talking about.
It's the filler words and the non-words.
Everybody does this. It's normal. It's
okay if you're doing it every now and
then. It only becomes a problem when you
use it every single sentence with every
single breath that you take. That's when
it becomes a problem, and it signals
that you're unsure, it makes you
unclear, and then you seem unconfident.
I hate to call this out, and I don't
mean to just pick on tech CEOs, but Mark
Zuckerberg, Elon Musk, you both also
belong here. I just want to be really
clear here. These are some of the most
brilliant thinkers on planet Earth, but
watch how they speak in these clips and
see if you can notice the behaviors we
just talked about. Go [__] yourself. Oh,
sorry. Sorry. Wrong clip. Wrong clip.
Roll the next one. Um uh
that's I I just want to really have um a
a global platform that brings together
like like I said, like it's becomes
close to sort of a collective
consciousness uh um and um you know,
like and one of the things that we've
introduced of You see that? You hear
that? The content of what they're saying
might be interesting, but the delivery,
the way they're saying it, it makes it
extremely difficult for you to listen,
right? I know what you're thinking here.
But then, these people are wildly
successful. They're even more successful
than you. What are you talking about?
They don't even need communication
skills. You know what? You're right. If
you are Mark Zuckerberg, if you are Elon
Musk, if you are Sam Altman, you don't
have to improve your communication
skills. These guys are pioneers. Go save
the world. Go get us to Mars. But if
you're a mere mortal like you and I, and
you're not as technically brilliant as
them, nor do you have billions of
dollars in your bank account, then I
encourage you. Don't stay a rookie.
Level up your communication skills. And
by the way, Sam, Mark, Elon, if you ever
want coaching personally directly with
me one-on-one, just DM me. I'll help you
amplify your impact.
Actually, sorry. Not you, Sam.
You're scary. Okay, moving into body
language. So, how do rookie
communicators use their body? Short
answer, they don't. And I mean that
literally. Zero expression. In this
category, people just don't know what to
do with their body. They don't know what
to do with their hands. They don't know
what to do with also the space that
they've been given. Guess what? They do
nothing with [music] any of it. They may
as well not have any bloody hands. And
just to make it clear for you what
rookie body language looks like and
awkward body language, come. Follow me.
Come follow me.
All right.
Come with me
on a wonderful adventure as we go and
explore the wilderness.
We're on the hunt for a strange
creature. Now, if we look through the
trees here,
what you can see is what we call Homo
erectus in his native habitat.
Notice his hands, terrible posture,
weird movements, and awful eye contact.
Oh god. Oh no. Hope he's realizing his
body language has failed him. Oh no.
He's now resorting to his mating call.
Oh god. We better get out of here.
Nature is relentless. So, the moral
The moral of the story is don't be like
Homo erectus, or as I like to call him,
Homo Peter.
>> [laughter]
>> It's time to evolve. Look, all jokes
aside, there was a time when I was
actually like Peter as well. And let's
call that version of Ben Homo Ben. Let
me bring you back to that time. When I
was 13, my entire year level, all the
guys had a crush on this one girl. Her
[music] name was Daniela. And I had a
strategy on how to win her love. I knew
that her parents drop her off really
early at school because they had to work
early. So, she would always be at school
at 8:00 a.m. So, I strategically was
also there at 8:00 a.m. And she was only
one at school. I was only one at school.
Oh, how weird. So, I would sit on the
other side of the bench to where she was
sitting because I was way too scared to
sit any closer. And every now and then,
just look over and admire her beauty.
But then, the moment she looks at me, I
would quickly look away because I was
too scared to make any eye contact. And
in my mind, I was thinking, "Oh my
goodness, this is like The Notebook. I'm
being so romantic." Without realizing
that I was coming across as a freaking
psychopath because that's all my body
language was communicating. Needless to
say, she thought I was a creep because I
was. What I hope you realize as we're
going through these behaviors is that
they're just behaviors. They're not
permanent. You can change them. You're
not a bad communicator. You just have
bad communication habits. And once you
learn the better vocal habits and the
better body language habits, you unlock
a whole new version of yourself that you
didn't know was possible. Don't be so
attached to who you are in the present,
you don't give the future version of you
a chance. All right. Now, how does a
rookie communicator use their words?
Well, there is no structure when they
speak at all whatsoever. They often
speak in circles. There's no clear point
to what they're saying. They're
literally just winging it. And as a
result, they ramble and they get stuck
in their thoughts, and this forces their
listener to do all of the cognitive work
as they try to decode what's actually
being said. In my communication classes,
I often get my students to do a simple
exercise, which gives them a completely
fresh perspective on whether or not
their communication is effective. I ask
them a random question on the spot, and
they have to give a 2-minute answer that
isn't scripted. And when we put that
into an AI tool like Gemini, which
transcribes the video into words, we now
can break down exactly how they're
structuring their sentences, where
they're repeating themselves and talking
in circles, and where they're not being
clear and concise. The reason people
never improve their communication skills
or ever move away from being a rookie is
because they never develop
self-awareness. So, you on the other
side of the screen right now, do the
same thing. Record a video of yourself
on your phone answering this question
for me. Why do you want to improve your
communication skills? Then put it into
Gemini as well and get it transcribed.
And then you can see, is it clear? Is it
concise? What are your filler words?
What are your non-words? This is how you
start your journey of developing
self-awareness. And if you don't do
this, you'll be forever stuck in rookie
land. So, here are my final picks for
rookie communicators. We have
Kamala Harris, Kim Kardashian.
Congratulations, you've made the board.
And finally, we have Lex Friedman. I'm
sorry, Lex. I really do like your
podcast, but I have to listen to it on
two times speed, otherwise I I I I can't
do it. I can't do I just can't do it.
Okay, now we're on to the next one.
Pretty good communicators. I'm going to
pin a few more faces into this category,
and I'm going to explain my decisions
why later. We got to go with Alex. Alex
Hormozi, you are going here. Serena
Williams, you're going right there.
Mark Manson, right there. And the final
person I'm putting here is NK BHND.
This is where things get interesting
because pretty good communicators have
actually done some work on the
communication. Maybe they've read some
books. Maybe they've even taken a few
courses like my online program, The
Stage Academy. Links in the description.
But here's what separates them from the
rookies. I want you to imagine this up
here. This up here, what you see there,
this is like a scale that represents the
full range of your communication
ability. Rookies only use a very small
part of the scale. For example, when it
comes to their voice, they default in
just one volume. They default with one
rate of speech. They default with one
pitch. They default to just one emotion.
Very monotone. Now, when you look at
pretty good communicators, what they do
is they start to use more of their
range. You'll notice that with their
voice, for example, they vary their
volume more. They'll start to vary their
body language more. And they're more
strategic with how they use their words.
So, let's zoom in to how pretty good
communicators use their voice. You know
this, they've got range. They know the
basics. They are not monotone. They have
melody. They know how to be dynamic with
their volume. They know how to use speed
to hold people's attention. And they're
not drowning in ums and ahs. But, here's
what keeps them stuck in pretty good.
Although they've got more range, they
play it too darn safe. And they're
afraid to play at the edges because
they're afraid that if they are too
playful with their voice and play at the
edges, people won't take them seriously.
And this is a natural fear. As you're
learning a new behavior and learning
something that's unfamiliar to you,
you're going to be scared of this. For
many of my students who come to my
classes, I force them to play outside of
their comfort zone. And I get them to
play keys on their instrument they've
never played before. And yes, it's
uncomfortable. And yes, what I'm trying
to do here is get you to unlock your
entire instrument, not just a small part
of it. Let me show you an example now
with old mate Homosi. Listen to this
clip of him speaking on Diary of a CEO.
Looked at the outliers among those and
we're like, oh, well, we also in some of
the ones that did really well, also had
some sort of visual picture of of this
plan. All right, so it became proof,
promise, plan, picture. Look, in this
clip, he's pretty good. He's pretty
good. He did vary his volume. He did
vary his rate of speech and pitch. But,
notice how he didn't play at the
extremes. But, I want you to watch him
in this interview now where he was
sitting across from Anthony Robbins. I
get married this Friday night.
It's Tuesday morning lately. But, but
that was infectious. Right? You know?
And and this is you, right? Okay, so who
is this guy?
>> ANABOLIC ALEX.
>> [laughter]
>> HE STARTED TO PLAY with his instrument
more. And look at the comments. Look at
the people praising him. They're saying,
"Wow, this is a version of Alex I've
never seen before." They're
complimenting how authentic he is, how
natural he is, how they're seeing all of
Alex. And that's what happens when you
use the entire range. And I just want to
remind you, the key thing that stops
people from using more of their range is
the fear of judgment. They are scared
that other people aren't going to take
them seriously. And as a result, they
don't play, they don't explore, and they
stay trapped being a pretty good
communicator. When they have the
potential to become so much better. Oh,
and uh PS, the fear that you have about
other people judging you, it's not real
because most people aren't thinking
about you anyway. They're thinking about
themselves. So, don't let a false fear
keep you trapped. Okay, body language.
How does a pretty good communicator use
their body? Well, come with me. Let's
see if Pete's evolved.
Oh, where is he? Oh, there he is.
Oh, okay. He's done some work on the
basics. He's not shrinking, not
fidgeting. Oh, his posture is solid. Oh,
he knows where his hands roughly should
be. He's making good eye contact. Oh,
but there's a problem. His gesture
vocabulary is limited to only a few
movements. And he keeps cycling between
the same ones. Gradually, Kent starts to
notice and he starts losing interest.
Peter, desperate at this point, attempts
to re-engage by moving faster and
faster. At this point, Kent's found a
more engaging mate. It's a disappointing
day for Peter Erectus.
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> That skit right there was to show you
what happens when you have limited
gesture vocabulary. Now, let's get into
a real example even the best
communicators fall victim to. Last year,
I went to go see Mark Manson, the author
of The Subtle Art of Not Giving a [__]
Now, I love this guy. I love his books,
his content, his wisdom. He's just
awesome. However, I want to show you how
repetitive non-functional body language
can rob you of influence and presence.
And how does one define non-functional
behaviors? Simple. If it distracts
people from the message, it's a problem.
It's non-functional. I want you to see
what Mark was doing that was distracting
his audience from the message. Do you
find this distracting? Do you think his
movements are necessary? Do you think
this adds to the message or do you think
it takes away from the message? What
about if I did this for the rest of the
video and I just kept moving around like
this? I want you to apply this lesson to
me right now because it doesn't matter
whether you are on a stage or you're
creating a YouTube video or you're
standing in front of two people talking,
repetitive movements like this, it
actually adds no purpose. And as a
result, it distracts people from the
message you're trying to say. So, the
rule here is simple. Only move with
purpose. If there's no reason for the
movement, don't move. Pro communicators
understand when to use movement and when
to harness the power of being still and
grounded. And they apply the sensitivity
to all areas of body language. So, do a
quick analysis on yourself right now.
When you communicate, do you use your
body language intentionally to support
the things you say? Or are you leaving
it up to chance? And do you know if
you're doing anything with your body
language that's distracting others? Do
you know what I used to do that I wasn't
even aware of? I kept touching my
glasses. And I would do this 10 times a
minute, 20 times a minute. Removing
these 1% of non-functional behaviors
over time, they compound. All right,
stay with me here. Once you learn how to
use your voice and your body language
well, you now need to learn how to turn
your thoughts into words faster and
structure your communication so that
it's clear and concise. This is where
pretty good communicators really start
to shine because they learn how to use
frameworks. Prep, star, 321, para, peel.
These are all acronyms that represent
all the different communication
frameworks. And there are dozens of
them. What they do is they help you
structure your thoughts before you
speak. Most people have the problem of
struggling to communicate on the spot
when they're put under pressure. This is
why people freeze. This is why people
ramble. This is why people end up
talking in circles. It's literally you
speaking out your thinking process which
people don't need to hear. But, what a
framework does is it acts as a filter.
It distills your thinking into a
meaningful, clear, concise, and coherent
response. Now, when you do this, the
person listening doesn't have to work to
follow your thinking because you've done
the work for them. The best
communicators use frameworks. And if you
want to learn my top three frameworks
that I use every single day and even in
this very video, make sure you check out
the free 2-hour crash course that I
recorded. I go a lot deeper on this
subject. When you learn these
frameworks, you'll be surprised how fast
you can turn your thoughts into words
and communication will feel easy. If
you've made it this far, well done!
Because you're about to learn the exact
behavior that makes someone appear to be
a natural communicator. Natural
communicators, they're not afraid of
using their entire range. This is where
I put the rest of the communicators here
on the table. Shadae here. Simon. Mel
Robbins. And finally, Neil deGrasse
Tyson. They all use their voice, their
body language, and they use their words
intentionally to get their message
across. And they do this effortlessly
and unconsciously. Unlike the rookie and
the pretty good communicators, natural
communicators no longer have to think
about it. They do this now
unconsciously. And the beautiful part
about this is now you bring this ability
into every single conversation, into
every single room that you step into.
That's why I believe improving this
skill will change your life
because you use it in every single area
of your life. Then, why are you even
whispering at this point? Well, because
Homo Erectus is back. Come [snorts] with
me. We have to be really quiet.
Look at him now. So refined. Seamless
integration between voice, body, and
words. Oh, look, he's managed to attract
another potential mate. Look, they're
frolicking.
Oh, look at them frolicking. This is the
highest praise one can achieve in the
animal kingdom. Homo Peter has done it.
>> [groaning]
>> Oh, god. These skits have been amazing.
Well done to my entire team. Hey, let's
celebrate them by liking the video and
subscribing. Catch great.
Oh, god. You're very good at
disappointing me and everybody in the
team. So, what does a natural
communicator sound like? They have
access to their full range like I said
before. But, let's dive into it more
specifically. They have five dials
available to them and they're using all
five dials simultaneously, full range
without even thinking about it. Rate of
speech. They can go fast to show passion
and then they can slow down to emphasize
what's important. Volume. They can go
loud to show vitality and then they can
soften their volume to show intimacy.
Pitch. They can go high pitch. They can
be really playful with their voice to
show warmth and playfulness. And then
they can go low pitch to show authority.
Tonality. They can inject emotion into
their voice to sound more authentic and
less robotic. The pause.
They know how to pause to create impact.
Now, I want you to listen to some of
these clips from the people here, and I
want you to see if you can notice them
using these five dials. There is so much
more that led to that situation. Maybe
that person was having a really bad day.
Maybe that person's relationship just
broke down, and you're meeting them
right at that point. Maybe they're in
pain.
And yet, we have this 1-second,
2-second, 1-minute interaction. Our
brain goes into what you see is all
there is.
And you forget that there's so much
else. What is the let them theory? So,
it's a simple truth about life. Okay. If
you want more peace, if you want more
power, if you want more time and energy,
stop trying to control and change other
people and learn how to let them be who
they are, let them have their opinions,
let them do what they're going to do,
and then focus that time and energy back
on yourself. We got our sense of belief
from church. Work was the place we made
our living. We had barbecues with our
neighbors, and over time those things
have disappeared, and now we demand of
our work that you be the place of of
purpose, you be the place of community,
you be the place of my social life, now
you be the place that matches my
politics. We're putting all this
pressure on work to fulfill every desire
I have, and we're doing the exact same
thing with our relationships. Notice the
variety across the five dials. The
variety in their voice is what holds
attention, creates engagement that leads
to influence. That's what makes these
communicators masterful. They use all
the elements of their voice. Next, how
do natural communicators use their body
language? What sets them apart from
everybody else is that they can express
their full range with intentional
expression. They have a larger gesture
vocabulary. They give more powerful eye
contact. They move with purpose, and the
most important is that they understand
the importance of facial expressions.
Because think about this. Where are most
people looking while you're talking?
Where are you looking right now? You're
looking at my face. People are looking
at your face the most while you're
talking. People don't realize that their
face is often a part of their body
language. Because of this, they never
engage in their face while they're
talking, and they end up with an RBF for
most of their lives, and they wonder why
people don't find them easy to connect
with. And let me explain why being able
to express emotion on your face is so
critical. When people see the emotion in
your face, but they don't hear the
emotion in your voice, then they don't
feel it. So, in order to make people
feel what you're saying, they need to
hear the emotion in your voice and see
the emotion in your face. The natural
communicators understand the importance
of syncing how they look to how they
sound, which ultimately impacts the way
people feel. That's an entirely
different plane of communication that
most never access. Just compare these
two examples of me saying something
without emotion and with emotion. I'm
really sorry, honey. I'll promise I'll
never forget Valentine's Day again. You
mean the world to me. I'm really sorry,
honey. I promise I'll I'll never forget
Valentine's Day again.
You mean the world to me. It made no
difference to my wife whether I had
emotion in what I said or not, because
she's still pissed about it. But for
most people, it's super effective. So,
whether you're a rookie or a pretty good
communicator, you can level up your
communication by simply learning how to
express more emotion with your face.
Because it brings you to life, and it
adds a layer of meaning that words alone
can't. And now to the final one, and
I'll reveal this right at the end,
because I want to demonstrate it for you
first. Natural communicators understand
that there are so many other ways to
communicate a message that aren't just
purely with using words. They have
frameworks. Yes, they do. They use them
all the time. But added to this, they
now use stories, analogies, activities,
props, David Attenborough skits like the
ones I've used throughout this video to
keep you engaged. So, for this example,
I'll show you how I can say the same
thing, but deliver it using an analogy,
a prop, and with a story. If I wanted to
communicate to you the message that you
should go and read more books, I could
simply tell you, "You should read more
books. Books are good."
Now, although this is true, it's not
very influential, is it? Now, let me
show you how I can communicate the same
thing with an analogy, a prop, and a
story. Reading is to the mind like
exercise is for the body. The more you
read, the healthier your mind becomes.
When someone creates a video on social
media, they might have just spent a few
hours thinking about what they're going
to say. What you're consuming, it's
momentary entertainment. But when
someone writes a book, this is
different. They've given years of their
life to get the message right. They've
taken years to distill every single
page, and this is a result of research,
experience, failure, and learning. So,
when you read this, you're not just
consuming information, you're absorbing
someone's life's work. That's a very
different thing as to consuming a social
media video.
Books are good. When I was in my
mid-20s, I lost half a million dollars
because of a single mistake that I made
with my online magic business. I was
sitting in a room feeling sorry for
myself, and then my dad walks in. And my
dad says to me, "Why do you think you
the fail?" And I shrugged, and I said,
"I don't know, man. I'm really not in
the mood for a lecture." And then he
walked straight over to my bookshelf,
and he pulls one of of my books off it,
and he waves in front of my face, and he
goes, "You fail because you have no the
soldier in the army."
And I remember thinking to myself,
"Don't give me this Confucius crap." And
then he says something truly brilliant,
my dad. He says, "Son, every time you
read a book, that author stands behind
you in an army ready to fight in
whatever battle you call him or her
soldiers if you want to win the battles
of entrepreneurship." Now, at that time,
I had about four books on my shelf. So,
that's four soldiers. Then he reached
into his pocket, grabbed his credit
card, and said, "Go build your damn
army." You know, the reason I'm telling
you this story is because often in life,
when you don't achieve the things you
want, it's rarely because you're not
capable. It's often because you just
don't know how. You don't have enough
soldiers in your army.
Books are good. Do you see how many ways
you could communicate the exact same
message of read more books? This is
their secret. They use their entire word
toolkit. The best communicators, the
natural communicators, they know exactly
when to use which one of those tools.
So, listen. I want you to know that no
matter where you are on your
communication journey, becoming a
natural communicator is possible. I
mean, how can I say this with such
conviction? Well, let me ask you. Where
do you think I fit on this board? Look
at this handsome chap in a turtleneck
trying to be like Steve Jobs. Where do
you think he goes? You're most likely
thinking that I go right here, don't
you? And if you were thinking that,
you're correct, because I'm pretty
bloody good, aren't I? But you know
what? You're also wrong, because
I've also been here. And I've also been
here, too. English is my third language.
I first learned Teochew, which is a
Chinese dialect, then I learned
Vietnamese, and only learned English
when I was about 8 years old. I
struggled with communication my entire
life. And as a kid from a refugee family
like mine, I went from being someone who
was completely invisible to now being
one of the most visible thought leaders
teaching the very skill that I used to
suck at. I mean, if that's not proof
that
being a natural communicator, becoming a
better communicator is possible, then I
don't know what is. What I'm saying is,
if I can do it, you can, too. You see,
there's a final mystery face that's on
the table here. I mean, who is that?
Well, that's actually
you.
But not you right now. This is the
future version of you. This is the
version of you that will be able to
become a
natural, a masterful communicator. So,
don't be so attached to who you are in
the present that you don't give this
future version of you a chance. Leave a
comment below. I'd love to get a sense
of where you're at on your communication
journey. And if you want to level up
immediately, make sure you go check out
my free crash course on communication
frameworks. That's in the description,
or once again, you can scan the QR code
that's on screen.
See you in the next video.